neue zahlen die britische mutation des
corona virus steckt mittlerweile hinter
jeder fünfte neuinfektionen in
deutschland eine frage des vertrauens
sorgen über nebenwirkungen und
akzeptanzprobleme beim impfstoff von
astrazeneca und ersehnte erfolg biathlet
arnd peiffer holte bei den
weltmeisterschaften silber über 20
kilometer und beendet den deutschen
medaillen fluch
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers abend in allen heute
um sieben an diesem aschermittwoch 2021
sport nachher in der sendung mit kristin
mit schönen erfolgen heute glaubt mehr
als jeder fünfte neue infizierte in
deutschland hat bereits die britische
variante von corona das ist die zahl die
heute aufmerken lässt zwischen sorge vor
den folgen und dem wunsch nach mehr
öffnung und einem ende des shutdown
da sollen schnelltests neben der impfung
zu echten perspektive werden mit
verspätung jetzt auch in deutschland
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
sagt die britische mutation habe jetzt
seinen anteil von mehr als 22 prozent
vor zwei wochen waren es noch knapp
sechs prozent demnach würde sich der
anteil in deutschland jede woche
ungefähr verdoppeln
die befürchtete ausbreitung ist für die
regierung ein grund dafür dass der
shutdown bislang beibehalten wird
obwohl die infektionszahlen insgesamt
zurückgehen
mehr von christiane hübscher in dieser
hamburger kita erleben sie gerade welche
wirkungen die britische mutation des
corona virus hat vor einer woche
infizierte sich hier eine mitarbeiterin
mit der virusvariante und steckte sechs
kinder und kolleginnen an diese
ansteckende mutationen kommt inzwischen
in allen bundesländern vor
mit rasantem wachstum so der
bundesgesundheitsminister wie auch schon
in anderen ländern beobachtet verdoppelt
sich der anteil der infektion mit dieser
virusvariante ungefähr jede woche wir
müssen damit rechnen dass die variante
bald auch bei uns die dominierende
werden könnte was aber bedeutet das wo
doch die virus lage in deutschland
insgesamt ermutigend ist mit instanzen
vielerorts unter 35
doch es gibt auch noch hotspots wie das
bayerische tirschenreuther an der grenze
zu tschechien in dem nachbarland ist die
britische virusvariante sehr stark
virologen warnen deshalb davor schon
bald zu viel zu öffnen wenn ich jetzt zu
früh ab einer bestimmten zahl locker
habe aber da schon einen nicht
unerheblichen anteil an varianten dabei
dann kann das sehr schnell passt
dass die zahlen ganz schnell wieder hoch
gehen das möchte ich gerne vermeiden ein
großer anteil von mutationen muss aber
nicht zwangsläufig eine dritte welle
auslösen sagen andere virologen bisher
zeige sich die maßnahmen wirken gut auch
gegen die virusvarianten das heißt
insbesondere für die lockerung pläne
dass wir beim testen und der
nachverfolgung besser werden müssen wir
testen mittlerweile wieder zu wenig wir
haben ein drittel weniger testungen im
vergleich zu weihnachten und das hat
natürlich auch auswirkungen auf die
dunkelziffer
und so soll es ab märz millionen von
antigen schnelltests geben mit termin
kostenlos zu haben in testzentren
apotheken arztpraxen die 18 euro pro
test soll der bund übernehmen
dazu kommen selbst tests für laien nach
zulassung im märz auch im discounter
erhältlich die schnelltest und diesel
ein selbsttest sind weitere wichtige
werkzeuge in dieser pandemie diese tests
können uns helfen einen sicheren weg zu
gehen jetzt auch gerade bei schulen und
kitas schnell und selbsttests geben zwar
keine 100 prozentige sicherheit können
aber ein schritt sein in richtung
normalisierung und gucken wir jetzt auf
die aktuellen corona zahlen innerhalb
eines tages verzeichnete das
robert-koch-institut 7556 neuinfektionen
das sind gut 500 weniger als vor einer
woche
560 menschen starben in verbindung mit
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
ist binnen einer woche von 68 auf jetzt
57 gesunken
nebenwirkungen nicht ausgeschlossen so
heißt es bei fast jedem medikament
nebenwirkungen bei einem corona
impfstoff da werden schnell alle
hellhörig und experten bekommen sorge
dass die bereitschaft der menschen sich
impfen zu lassen darunter leidet die
details sind also entscheidend in zwei
kliniken in deutschland haben sich teile
des personals nach der impfung mit dem
mittel von astrazeneca krankgemeldet sie
klagen über kopfschmerzen müdigkeit und
fieber
die genehmigungsbehörden bezeichnen die
nebenwirkungen als normal peter kunz
boris johnson und astrazeneca der
britisch-schwedische impfstoffes der
stolz des premierministers mit dem er
auf den britischen inseln tempo beim
impfen macht ohne große probleme mit
diesem vakzin ohne vorübergehende
impfstoffs wie zum beispiel in
braunschweig im herzogin elisabeth
krankenhaus wurde personal gm fast die
hälfte davon fiel dann erst mal aus mit
fieber und grippe symptomen es hat mich
keiner wir haben natürlich nicht so
einen hohen anteil der nebenwirkung
erwartet werden etwa zehn prozent
erwartet wie die studienlage es hergibt
astrazeneca reagiert gegenüber dem zdf
derzeit sind die gemeldeten reaktionen
so wie wir sie aufgrund der erkenntnisse
aus unserem klinischen studienprogramm
erwarten würden dazu gehören
vorübergehende lokale reaktionen wie
kopfschmerzen schüttelfrost fieber
die reaktionen traten häufiger einen tag
nach der impfung auf astrazeneca in
deutschland empfohlen bis zum alter von
64 jahren hat mit 70 prozent einen
geringeren wirkungsgrad als andere
impfstoffe weniger nutzen mehr
beschwerden so sagt auch im krankenhaus
mancher nein zu dieser impfung
was passiert ist ist mir einfach zu hoch
für den schutz den wir am endeffekt
haben wie bei einen geringen schutz als
gar keinen schutz war der mangel an
impfstoff den wir im moment haben würde
ich immer noch empfehlen sich mit
astrazeneca impfen zu lassen
der bundesgesundheitsminister war heute
für vertrauen der fraktion sind übrigens
ja erst mal durchaus kein schlechtes
zeichen sie zeigen dass das immunsystem
reagiert
auch in braunschweig wird jetzt nur noch
geimpft wer danach dienstfrei oder
wochenende hat um mögliche
impfreaktionen auszukurieren
ja es gibt also bei manchen im
gesundheitswesen offensichtlich
vorbehalte gegen astrazeneca und jetzt
in mehreren bundesländern die etwas
absurde situation dass plötzlich
ungenutzter impfstoff übrig ist theo
koll guten abend wie will denn die
politik damit umgehen
ja das lässt sich wohl nur noch über
gezielte aufklärung lösen denn die
frühen studien über astra zeneca die
hatten ja wirklich deutlich niedriger
wirksamkeits werte ermittelt
mittlerweile zeigen aber wir haben es
gerade auch gehört die neuen zahlen dass
die wirksamkeit dieses international
jahr zugelassen und geprüften impfstoffs
deutlich höher ist der ist zwar immer
noch etwas geringer als bei den anderen
beiden impfstoffen aber es ist ein sehr
hoher schutz und natürlich allemal
besser als nicht geimpft zu sein für die
politik ist diese impfzurückhaltung ein
massives problem denn von den bisher
gelieferten fast 740 1000 impfdosen sind
bisher nur zehn bis zwölf prozent
überhaupt verimpft worden und morgen
kommen schon die nächsten 740.000 ende
kommender woche dann noch mal über eine
million also um diesen stau zu lösen so
sagt mir eben das gesundheitsministerium
würde man den impfstoff dann den
nächsten priorität gruppe anbieten die
geben dann einfach früher dran aktuell
also zu viele dosen von astrazeneca
impfstoff zumindest für den moment t
herzlichen dank die deutschen und der
astra zeneca impfstoff über die bedenken
reden wir mit einem mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission und auch sie
können fragen stellen ab 20 uhr bei zdf
heute live in unserer app bei youtube
oder auf facebook
wir bleiben noch moment beim thema
impfen die eu fordert in großem stil
impfstoff nach 300 millionen zusätzliche
dosen sollen vom us-unternehmen moderner
kommen und außerdem ist jetzt der
vertrag mit bayer pfizer über bis zu 300
millionen zusätzliche dosen unter dach
und fach
die eu-kommission hat eine reihe von
neuen maßnahmen der korona krise
vorgestellt so soll künftig mehr auf
neue virus mutationen getestet werden
impfstoffe gegen neue varianten sollen
beschleunigt zugelassen werden können
und die zusammenarbeit mit den
herstellern soll verstärkt werden um die
produktion aufzustocken
der politische aschermittwoch in
deutschland in der pandemie fühlt sich
auch der sehr anders an
zwar sprachen sie alle wie sonst auch
aber eben nicht angriffslustig bis derb
vor großem publikum im zelt und saal
sondern eher einsam in die kameras
das hauptthema corona und wie die
politik damit umgeht viel zündstoff also
in einem wahljahr patricia schäfer wo
leibhaftige zuschauer fehlen müssen
pappkameraden herhalten die csu fühlt
die lehre dreiländerhalle mit kulissen
während die zuschauer zuhause sich mit
fanartikeln in stimmung bringen
es ist eine sorgsame choreografierte
regie sogar an transparente mit
lobeshymnen wurde gedacht csu chef
markus söder ernster als sonst
verteidigt seine corona politik nur eins
ist wie immer er teilt aus gegen die
anderen mir kommt die spd in hamburg vor
wie schalke 04 die schalke 04
ja eigentlich im großen namen tolle
geschichte aber echt schlechtes spiel
ein novum beim politischen
aschermittwoch die csu hat einen gast
geladen
wenn cdu und csu so eng beieinander
stehen wie im moment dann werden wir
auch dieses wichtige wahljahr für
deutschland im einsamen bestehe
wenige kilometer weiter in vilshofen
präsentiert sich die fpd zwischen
biertheke und holzpaletten auch dass
eine gewollte inszenierung als bühne für
ihren kanzlerkandidaten
auch hier haben wir ja einige politiker
die die pose wichtiger finden als die
tat die viel das fordern was niemals
kommt und das dann durch die nächste
forderung zu ersetzen
die grünen versuchen mit musik stimmung
in die virtuelle welt zu bringen
auch hier herrscht eine
zielgruppenorientierte
wohnzimmeratmosphäre jetzt endlich
vorbei sein muss ist das politische auf
sicht fahren wir müssen raus aus dieser
politik des abwartens der
beschwichtigung zmo duss die fdp
positioniert sich als potenzieller
koalitionspartner mit weniger aufwand im
bühnenbild und dem parteichef vor
panorama wir haben keine präferenz
welches parteibuch der nächste kanzler
oder die nächste kanzlerin hat wir
wollen nur eins eine andere politik
gestalten die linke in einem leeren
passauer traditionslokal zugeschaltet
thüringens ministerpräsident
corona zeigt nur was foto oder alles
schon falsch gelaufen ist es ist der
brandbeschleuniger bei dem auch die
entsolidarisierung der gesellschaft
mittlerweile zu einem großen thema
geworden ist als einzige partei mit
etwas publikum will die afg ein zeichen
setzen
der lock down maßnahmen horror das muss
auf dem tisch und das muss man den
wahlen abgestraft werden
der politische aschermittwoch 20 21
bundestagswahl lässt grüßen
in den usa haben sie wahl und wahlkampf
hinter sich bei den republikanern aber
wird immer heftiger über das wie weiter
gestritten
in der partei ist ein offener machtkampf
ausgebrochen befeuert von donald trump
der neue präsident versucht inzwischen
das anzugehen was wir vor der wahl
versprochen hatte corona bekämpfen und
mit viel geld auch die folgen aus
washington tom pollock joe biden ist
gegen korona geimpft der moderator
negativ getestet und die 50 gäste im
theater von milwaukee halten maskiert
abstand beim ersten bürgergespräch des
präsidenten sind die pandemie und die
impfungen das große thema bis ende juli
werden wir über 600 millionen dosen
haben genug um jeden einzelnen
amerikaner zu impfen
impfen ist die eine große hoffnung
beiden 1,9 billionen dollar hilfspaket
die andere arbeitslose die familien die
schulen sollen davon profitieren
viel geld doch biden sieht viele
wirtschaftsexperten auf seiner seite
jetzt ist die zeit für den großen wurf
wenn wir allein dieses gesetz
verabschieden schaffen wir sieben
millionen jobs dieses jahr über einen
den ehemaligen typen wie er ihn nennt
will biden an diesem abend aber nicht
sprechen
vier jahre ging es in den nachrichten
nur um thom in den nächsten vier jahren
will ich dafür sorgen dass es in den
nachrichten um das amerikanische volk
geht
doch der ex präsident bleibt in den
schlagzeilen und wettert gegen einen
ehemals engen vertrauten mitch mcconnell
dem fraktionschef der republikaner im
senat tram schreibt mit ist ein
mürrischer missmutiger unfreundlicher
politischer nichtsnutz wenn die
republikanischen senatoren an ihm
festhalten werden sie nie wieder
gewinnen
mcconnell hatte schon mehrfach für die
gewalt im capitol mitverantwortlich
gemacht auch wenn er ihm im pitch bend
für einen freispruch turms gestimmt
hatte
die republikaner schweigen bislang zu
trumps neuen aussagen mit denen er den
richtungsstreit seiner partei weiter
befeuert seit monaten gehen in belarus
immer wieder menschen auf die straße um
gegen machthaber alexander lukaschenko
zu protestieren
sie prangern willkürliche verhaftungen
an und wahlbetrug einer von lukaschenko
wichtigsten gegenkandidaten bei der
präsidentenwahl letztes jahr war dieser
mann der oppositionelle victor barcot
bis er dann zwei monate vor der wahl
festgenommen wurde
jetzt muss sich bei ricoh wegen
korruption und geldwäsche vor gericht
verantworten
er sagt das ist ein politischer
schauprozess
christian senn berichtet lasst uns rein
fordern unterstützer von victor barcot
vor dem gerichtsgebäude in minsk drin
beginnt der prozess wegen angeblicher
korruption bestechung und geldwäsche
gegen den oppositionellen victor barcot
in einem käfig vorgeführt wie ein
schwerverbrecher
ich weiß nicht barrick ist wichtig für
die menschen und daher sind sie gekommen
um ihn zu unterstützen
der ex-banker baba rico galt in belarus
als aussichtsreicher
präsidentschaftskandidat bis zu seiner
festnahme im juni 2020 sieben wochen vor
der wegen manipulationsvorwürfen so
umstrittenen wahl in seinem team
arbeitete auch maria callas in koffer
die dann zum gesicht der massenproteste
wurde und ebenfalls im gefängnis sitzt
machthaber lukaschenko versteht die
aufregung nicht und demütigte baba rico
letzte woche öffentlich für alle machen
so einen rummel wegen barbarie co
man hat den konkurrenten des präsidenten
eingesperrt auf solche konkurrenten
pfeife ich ein halbes jahr nach der wahl
sind die proteste kleiner geworden dass
lukaschenko system hat alles brutal
niedergeschlagen musik das siegen alles
offensichtlich man setzt auf nackte
gewalt auf politische repressionen auf
unterdrückung und auch säuberung der
politischen landschaft das findet jeden
tag statt in form von verhaftungen
gerichtsverhandlungen und haus
durchsuchen das gerichtsverfahren gegen
bubba rico ist teil dieser langfristigen
strategie die das lukaschenko regime
verfolgt bei einer verurteilung drohen
victor war bei ricoh bis zu 15 jahre
gefängnis zurück nach deutschland
großeinsatz für polizei und sanitäter
heute in der konzernzentrale des
lebensmittel-discounters lidl in
neckarsulm in baden württemberg am
nachmittag explodierte dort eine brief
oder paketbombe das hat die polizei
bestätigt drei menschen wurden demnach
leicht bis mittelschwer verletzt
ein verwaltungsgebäude wurde geräumt die
hintergründe sind noch völlig unklar
einen schritt richtung elektromobilität
verkündet heute die europäische sparte
von ford der autohersteller investiert
knapp eine milliarde euro in sein kölner
werk ab 2023 sollen dort dann reine e
fahrzeuge vom band rollen
die ford für europa bisher gar nicht im
programm hat partner des projekts ist
volkswagen am 2030 will ford hierzulande
dann nur noch autos verkaufen und damit
sind wir in der sendung beim sport und
bei kristin und haben endlich jubel im
biathlon riesen-erleichterung zu beginn
der zweiten wm woche im slowenischen
pokljuka an käufer gewinnen silber im
einzel insgesamt drei deutsche männer
unter den top ten vielleicht die
ersehnte initialzündung für das zuvor
medaillenlose team
und eifer mit dem ersten edelmetall
balsam für die gebeutelte seele der bis
dato nicht überzeugenden biathleten ein
bisschen glück muss man schon auch mal
haben im biathlonsport uns männer
ziemlich natürlich für alle da ist es
freut mich riesig
die basis für diese silbermedaille bei
20 schuss 20 treffer endlich ist sie
zurück die treffsicherheit am
schießstand dazu eine gute laufform
nur einer ist besser der junge norweger
us-dollar highlight der größte triumph
für den 23 jährigen
bronze geht an johannes tolle ebenfalls
noch wegen ja und bereits die vierte
medaille haben die deutschen aktiven bei
den alpinen weltmeisterschaften in
cortina d'ampezzo verbucht im team-event
reichte es durch den erfolg im kleinen
finale gegen olympiasieger und
titelverteidiger schweiz zu bronze
riesengroße freude war andreas
österreicher stefan lurz und alexander
schmid nach dem slalom team event nach
platz 4 gestern sich jetzt schmid links
als schlussfahrer deutschland platz drei
gegen die schweiz
ja es war echt schlecht 1 sehr lässige
tag im team macht 60 stream viel spaß
jeder schlecht sehr gut skifahren jubel
über bronze bei den deutschen gold und
silber machen norwegen und schweden
unter sich aus norwegen hat am ende die
nase vorn
es ist die vierte medaille für
deutschland bei diesen titelkämpfen
fehlt noch eine zur erfolgreichsten wm
seit 43 jahren
ein tolles wetter ernüchterung bei rb
leipzig nach der 0 2 niederlage gegen
den fc liverpool im achtelfinal-hinspiel
der fußball-champions-league zwei böse
fehler der leipziger hierdurch sabitzer
in der 53 minute der brummt von moser
für die reds genutzt wurde
fünf minuten später grätschte mobile ins
leere und manet hellwach mit dem zweiten
treffer für die mannschaft von jürgen
klopp in budapest und nachher will es
dortmund in serie besser machen
abwarten kristin dankeschön jetzt ist
zeit für so eine art nachtisch wir in
der sendung wir bekommen heiß auf eis
serviert nee eis auf heißt so
und zwar auf sizilianische art der ätna
spuckte lava in den schnee und auch
diese zutat ist eher ungewöhnlich eine
riesige aschewolke die selbst ein
bisschen aussieht wie fließende lava
alles zusammen übrigens absolut
ungefährlich meinen experten einfach nur
schön anzusehen
respekt hat man trotzdem die lottozahlen
jetzt noch und die lauten 14 25 29 40 48
superzahl 9 weitere gewinnzahlen wie
immer auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text
das ist ein februar der extreme erst gab
es so viel schnee wie selten dann
bitterkalte nacht temperaturen und jetzt
kommt der frühling wie schön
mehr dazu gleich von katja horneffer
dann empfehle ich ihnen das heute schon
mal mit dem kollegen claus kleber um
21.45 von uns allen hier danke für das
interesse gerne bis morgen und ihnen
allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren einige
flusspegel melden bereits hochwasser und
die wasserstände werden jetzt ganz genau
beobachtet obwohl derzeit der schnee nur
langsam taut das könnte sich aber ändern
denn eine richtige wahl luftblase
breitet sich hier über mitteleuropa aus
der höhepunkt der milden temperaturen
wird aber gar nicht mehr in dieser woche
erreicht sondern wahrscheinlich erst
mitte nächster woche
es kommt nicht nur sehr milde luft heran
sondern zum teil auch etwas regen heute
nacht regnet es hier nördlich von
hannover und berlin etwas im süden es
ist zum teil klar da blitzt ich auch
mein label oder dunst hier unter dem
klaren sternenhimmel sinken die
temperaturen zum teil auf null bis minus
fünf grad unter den dichteren wolken im
norden bleibt es bei sieben bis zwei
grad milder morgen erwarten uns
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 4 grad auf
rügen und 17 grad am oberrhein
vormittags kann es in mecklenburg
vorpommern noch ein bisschen regnen
sonst beginnt der donnerstag häufig mit
sonnenschein wenn nicht nebel oder dunst
stören nachmittags aber verändert sich
das dann setzt nämlich regen ein hier
zwischen dem emsland und der mosel dafür
hört der regen in mecklenburg vorpommern
auf und in den nächsten tagen wird es
von tag zu tag sonniger und wärmer am
sonntag erwarten uns neun bis 20 grad
schönen abend noch